this video is sponsored by notion the
only constant in life is change as i was
joining the tech industry right after
college that was one of the resounding
pieces of advice i got from my seniors
around me and you know what i think that
being a software engineer really helped
to prepare and teach me to internalize
that i like to think of it as being
light on my feet like not getting stuck
in any one place or thing for too long
so that i can adapt smoothly and easily
and i think that through my adult life
i've gotten used to not just adapting to
big life changes but really embracing
them too it's one of those things though
that's easier said than done it's easy
to say that we'll be ready for changes
but when it comes with discomfort facing
harsh realities and the need to be brave
it's safe to say that change brings
about challenges for us that we must
rise up to and not to mention i have
anxiety so i'm scared of a lot of things
and i'm always worried therapies help me
to address it on a personal level as i
move through times of change but anxiety
is definitely just very common when
you're dealing with the unknown and
you're feeling the undercurrent of
change underneath your feet and in
software we don't really talk about
anxiety so much and instead we focus on
ambiguity as the core of this phenomenon
there's a ton of like articles and
videos and talks about how to mitigate
and manage ambiguity and software but i
really think it just comes down to
learning as much as you can about the
ambiguous thing and then planning for it
so if a project itself is ambiguous or
maybe adding a new technology has
ambiguity then gathering as much
information as possible to then make an
informed plan
on what steps to take next is one way to
make everything go smoother in fact
that's something that i even brought to
my work as a content creator because my
work if anything is super ambiguous
literally the work that i do is just so
different from anything i've done before
and there's no paved path in front of me
and a lot of times i can't exactly ask
family or friends for like career advice
because my family and friends are also
not youtubers it's just the work i do is
just so different from anything i've
ever done before and there isn't like a
paved career path in front of me and so
i have to kind of figure out a lot of
this stuff on my own as i do it because
everyone does content differently they
create different types of videos and
posts to a different type of audience in
a different way that works for the
creator themselves it's still really
easy to lose myself and like the great
mess of social media and get lost in the
ambiguity but luckily software
engineering has taught me some really
valuable lessons and how to work through
this so what does that actually look
like in practice well it looks like
ideating on video ideas with my team on
what would be interesting to make and
also watch on youtube it also means
creating weekly plans for how to bring
that video to life and scheduling those
in the future and then tracking the
progress of those videos while gathering
feedback reducing ambiguity through
planning is something that i used in my
personal life this year as well as my
husband and i embarked on a kitchen
renovation on our new home
we started with what we thought we might
want the end product to be with
brainstorm docs which then resulted in
putting together a detailed pdf for a
contractor to share with him our vision
for a future kitchen and then throughout
our renovation keeping track of our own
to do's like ordering parts and making
calls to subcontractors for things like
flooring and countertops we even tracked
our budget too to make sure that we were
spending our money in the right places
and we could keep track of our spending
all of these things ideating
collaborating planning and tracking all
help me to crystallize the goals that i
have in both my personal and work life
to help me work through the mountain of
ambiguity that exists because again
change is the only constant and these
days i want change i want to engage with
the ever-changing tides of life as i
embark on new challenges and learn new
things i mean after all it's going
through these changes that are gonna
help us to learn some of the most
valuable life lessons rather than the
end result itself staying curious and
moving through life seasons is i think
one of the best ways to feel like you're
living
thank you so much for watching this
video i really hope you liked it i just
want to say thank you again so much to
notion for partnering with me on this
video and helping me to move through all
the life's changes easily and
thoughtfully notion is an amazing
collaboration tool that helps you dream
plan work and build with others the way
you want
genuinely notion is just one of my
favorite tools it's really helped
enhance everything that i need about
note-taking planning i dating
collaborating i actually did a notion
setup tour earlier this year and if you
haven't checked that out i'll link it
right here and if you're interested in
also inviting notion into your life get
started for free and create a new
teamwork space and or invite a team
member to a notion page using my link
don't forget to subscribe as always and
i'll see you next time bye
[Music]